this is a production of Cornell
University
well good afternoon everyone so my
name's Kyle I'm in the Missouri Club and
I'm going to be continuing our
discussion on disease resistance but I
will be talking about mapping mapping
disease resistance genes in key
curvature species so I'm going to talk
today a little bit about two different
categories I'm going to talk about
resistance to viruses and in particular
the viruses that I'm working with our
cucumber mosaic virus and then three
pody viruses papaya ringspot watermelon
mosaic and zucchini yellow mosaic and
then also I will be talking about our
work in mapping partner mildew
resistance specifically this gene pm0 my
work is being done in Cuba to pepo which
is the species that includes things like
zucchini summer squash some winter
squash pumpkins things like that and
while this species is very important for
all of these market classes that really
aren't a lot of resistant genes to be
found there's no native resistance to
any of these diseases in keek urban
people so because of that breeders have
been forced to go to other species for
virus resistance the most common source
of resistance for those four viruses are
coming from Nigeria and local and menina
these are too old old varieties of
Cucurbita moschata
Cucurbita moschata is like a
butternut-squash tropical pumpkin that
type of thing and they can cross pretty
well with Cucurbita pepo so we've been
in the past it's been used to bring in
those disease resistances but people
also use this variety called Whitacre
which is an interesting variety name for
this man Thomas Whitaker a famous
cucurbit geneticist and it has
resistance that it's been brought into a
cocoon of people species but it's from
three related wild species so it has a
very interesting pedigree and people
have been using this as a bridge so they
don't have to try to cross with all
these crazy wild species and
very rarely people are using teacher
Buddha Ecuador iNSYS which is one of
those related wild species that is much
more difficult to cross with but it does
have resistance so to get started on
this I was looking for any variety that
was listed as having some resistance to
any of these viruses and I got a pretty
good collection of mostly curative
people some masada
and a bunch of different market classes
but unfortunately for our two most
important viruses CMV and PR SP just
aren't that many resistant cultivars
available right now so what I'm doing
moving forward is evaluating these and
trying to pick the best ones to start
developing segregating populations so we
can move forward with that and have more
of a combination there and for the
bottom two WMV 0mv at least we have a
few more varieties there so we can start
doing more mapping with those so I'm
going to just zoom in and talk about
just one of these viruses papaya
ringspot virus this is a devastating
disease causes just terrible fruit
deformation and then the plants are
stunted and they look disgusting and
nobody wants to buy this so you could
eat it but you went to a store nobody's
going to buy something like that so I
focusing on this one because it is
unique in that it's one of the poses
that in the past resistance has been
described by a single recessive gene so
my my thought is that the most likely
candidate gene for this is this CIF 4 E
which is a translation initiation factor
that interacts directly with the five
prime cap of mrna and it's been shown in
other species that mutations in this
gene will result in a recessive
resistance to mostly pody viruses so
that's encouraging and also a few other
classes so here's a little cartoon of
how this works so yeah for you as part
of this whole translation initiation
complex and it binds directly to this
genome associated viral protein that is
acting as the five prime cap for virus
RNA and if there is a mutation in this
protein and it can't bind properly then
this whole complex doesn't form and
translation doesn't happen the virus
can't spread so so moving forward with
that
I'm just looking for any possible
candidate genes from other
transcriptomic works that have been
identified in curative species and I'm
going to start sequencing those genes
looking for any polymorphism that could
be really leading to these mutations
that would inhibit this finding and then
I'm also working to develop more
matching populations and doing more
screening okay so changing gears a
little bit I'm going to talk a little
bit now about
powdery mildew resistance so perhaps
some of you remember Bill Holdsworth
talking about this work so we have
mapped the major powdery mildew
resistance gene that's present in most
of the Popes parts that are available
today we used a an integration mapping
approach where we knew that these
resistance came from one particular wild
species and it happened in one
introgression event so we were able to
find this candidate interval of about
500 KB that all of the resistant
varieties shared and none of the
susceptible varieties had and with
additional fine mapping we got that down
to about 76 Kb and we developed a marker
that was predictive in key Corbett of
people but to keep going with this we
really wanted to figure out what is the
actual gene involved what what causal
polymorphism is happening right now our
marker is just sort of tagging this
introgression so to start I was working
through this analysis again and I redid
what we did using the new mo shadow
genome that's available which is much
more complete than the Pico reference
that we were using initially and found
one strong signal which is confirming
what we found using the other reference
genome so that was very encouraging and
then I zoomed in on that region looking
at about 80 KB and we have about a dozen
or so possible genes in here that have
annotations and there are two in
particular that I really want to focus
in on and that's this NBS lrr gene and
this part of millet resistance protein
that has the RP WH domain so these if
it's going to be any of these this is
where I want to put most of my effort
because this MBS LR gene is a very
common our gene for a lot of different
species and the powdery mildew
resistance protein with the RP WH domain
is very specific to powdery mildew and
it's been shown in few other species but
that is what is causing resistance so to
really get into this for these two
candidate genes we've been doing a lot
of sequencing did some rt-pcr and we
found that they are expressed in both
the resistant and susceptible varieties
so there must be something else going on
it's not just presence/absence so we're
trying to do additional sequencing and
using race to pull out the entire
sequence of these genes from both
resistant and susceptible varieties and
we're looking for polymorphism that
could be leading to this change and once
we are a little bit more confident that
one of these two genes is most likely
our best candidate then we're thinking
about moving forward with either a virus
induced gene silencing technique to
knock out the expression of the gene in
the resistant plants try to bring it
down to a susceptible level or possibly
using any transformation techniques that
could be like an ultimate confirmation
that our chem gene is in fact the causal
gene so with that I'd like to just thank
the members of Missouri lab especially
page reads for all for help with the
powdery mildew work my committee members
and my funding through Q cap then
allowing me to really dig into some of
these different a lot of different
diseases
which are really important to the key
kerbin for community at large so thank
you
[Applause]
so there you know there are even a lot
of work done in tea curb excusing that I
think one that has been shown to work at
least in proof of concept is I think
it's like Apple spherical latent fire or
something like that so that has been
shown at least to work in
proof-of-concept but not a lot of work
has been done using bigs in cucurbits so
that would be something that I wanted to
use that first would have to get the
system working and then go from there
but that sounds kind of fun to me so yes
so that is it's present all throughout
the United States I'm not exactly sure
where it came from but it also can
affect papayas Tussauds
it's that same sort of virus but it
pretty much infects papayas and then
kicker baits and not a whole lot else
it's not like CMV that can infect like a
thousand different things yes
mm-hmm
so that is a good question there's a lot
of redundancies so if the cell has other
like different versions of this it could
still function normally and it might
just be that there's specific yeah F or
E virus interactions that aren't working
but with the cap protein of the mRNA
that's in plant cells that's slightly
different than this viral cap protein so
that interaction might not work with the
virus but it could still work with the
mRNA from the plant cell it's a pretty
common mechanism of resistance to assess
advisors like that this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu